that's what I love about money no
emotions no tears just reality it's been
a remarkable 10 years I'm seeking a
$100,000 investment over a thousand
entrepreneurs have walked down these
halls seeking their piece of the
American dream with close to 125 million
dollars invested in the tank so far he's
gonna change the world
and astounding successes it ignited
America's entrepreneurial spirit and now
the Sharks are back for an epic 10th
season
I see more beverages than anybody else
in the country you may not have to go
out and raise money if you partner with
someone like me and exciting titans of
business return I want to know a little
bit more about you I think that watching
shark tank as a kid helped me be
standing in front of you all today we
got on this show and remember there's
only one mr. wonderful but they got for
that and brand-new sharks jump into the
tank former NBA superstar and
broadcaster Charles Barkley is a
prolific investor and committed to
helping entrepreneurs you seem to be on
the right track and I'm willing to take
the chance Matt Higgins is vice
president of the Miami Dolphins and his
co-founder of RSE ventures which invests
in innovative companies across multiple
sectors including sports lifestyle and
technology when we work together it's
gonna be game over
as we celebrate our 200th episode an
epic milestone for the first time ever a
former Shark Tank entrepreneur achieves
the ultimate goal of go and returns as a
shark shark tank has inspired a nation
to chase their dreams this has been a
lot of my life I just want to share that
with people
there is a tenacity that I have and
nothing's gonna stop me what you've done
is just inspiring and the dream
continues now and then they say you're
wrong I'm never wrong I'm always right I
will make you a millionaire look I'm
rich I'm really really really rich
welcome to shark tank look I'm just an
investor trying to scratch out a living
here okay
[Music]